Parce qu’un peu de rébellion ça ne fait pas de
mal, j’admire la révolution. Je n’en sais rien.
Aurélien Pradié, député du Lot et
secrétaire général des Républicains.
Instagram, parce qu’on écrit moins et donc
on a moins de chance de dire des conneries.
Aucun des deux. Dans le Sud-Ouest
c’est une terre de Rugby. On parle
d’un vrai sport. On parle de Rugby.
Plutôt Canard laqué. Ça fait moins mal,
en le lisant qu’en le mangeant.
NTM, parce qu’un peu de rébellion,
ça ne fait pas de mal !
Plutôt aucun des deux. Plutôt la Mique lotoise, le
pastis lotois. Le gâteau, à ne pas confondre avec
la boisson ! Plutôt le Lot, avant tout le Lot.
Difficile... Simone Veil parce qu’elle a fondé
un de mes engagements politique essentiel.
Les deux sont les mêmes !
Christian Jacob. Parce que je n’aurai
pas aujourd’hui l’engagement politique que j’ai,
sans avoir croisé le chemin de Christian Jacob.
Il parait que la barbe fait plus sage, plus
sérieux. Mais je ne le crois plus depuis
qu’Edouard Philippe la porte.
Plutôt Astérix, j’aime bien
les petits bonhommes un peu rebels.
Plutôt le Général de Gaulle. Un héros ! Différent
de Napoléon. Un vrai héros tel que nous ne
l’avons plus, à une époque qui n’est plus la même.
Plutôt The Young Pop.
Plutôt « Le père Noël est une ordure ». Je pense
que c’est le seul film où je connais un peu près
toutes les répliques. « Un exemple ? » Qu’est-ce
que vous avez foutu dans les cases, ça déborde !
Nakamura, non pas du tout. Céline Dion un peu
moins, mais un peu plus quand même. Nina Simone !
Plutôt Intouchables parce que le Handicap
est pour moi un sujet majeur.
Si je dis Karl Marx je vais
me faire engueuler, sauf que c’est celui
que j’ai le plus lu. Plus que Léon Blum.
Plutôt circonscription résolument, parce
que c’est là que tout a commencé pour moi.
Et Palais Bourbon pour les grandes émotions,
parce que ce n’est pas un lieu comme les autres.
Surement Girondins mais croyant
profondément à la force de l’état,
à la force de la nation. Et donc le bon
équilibre, entre les Girondins et les Jacobins.
Plutôt pied sur terre parce que c’est
là que tout commence et c’est le sens
de la politique. D’abord les grands
rêves mais de trouver des solutions.